Wonderful.
Ofer Wellisch, thank you
for being with me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Good. Thanks for having me, Michael.
One of the things
that I said right before this
is I love the design of your home,
the light bulbs especially.
I think they're fantastic.
Really fabulous.
Well, I had nothing to do with it.
Sounds great.
Ofer, you're calling me from New York.
So, first of all, thank you
for taking the call so late.
I really appreciate it.
And your chief division of pain medicine
at Stamford Health, right?
But you were also
an attending physician at Stanford.
A limited partner at J- Ventures.
So, I'm really curious to hear about you.
You have one leg in medicine, as a doctor.
Another leg as an investor in MedTech.
And I'd love to allude eventually also
to what's happening today with covid
and how you're seeing this unfold
as we go along .
So, Ofer, take us on your journey.
I want to go back to Tel Aviv University.
Studying medicine, what is it like?
Do you know that you're going to be
passionate about pain medicine
throughout your life?
It's great questions there.
A lot of questions.
Yeah. So, actually,
when I was a master's student at GW
prior in medical school,
I'd done my thesis, my master's thesis
at the National Institutes of Health.
And I got in touch with the lab
that was studying molecular pain
and molecular neuroscience.
And this is a really great
growth opportunity for me.
The intramural program
in Bethesda Maryland for the NIH
is just a wonderful place
to just meet great mentors.
Get a lot of to your hands
on a lot of different
experimental techniques in medicine,
and just also meet a lot of personalities
that have been
very successful in medicine.
And so, from there,
I went on to medical school.
And I kept really good communication
with my mentors in the whole concept
of pain medicine and some of the concepts
we have been working on.
Wait. Ofer, what is pain medicine?
Just for background really quick,
what is pain medicine?
Right. So, we could talk a little bit
about chronic pain.
And pain medicine is essentially,
the practice of treating pain.
And evolutionarily, acute pain
has a purpose.
So, if a person back in the old times
injured themselves,
they go back to their cave
so the lion doesn't eat them, for example.
So, pain served a protective purpose.
Right?
Today, we have what's called chronic pain.
So, patients get injured.
Whether it's at work
or the sporting incident.
Their injuries actually heal,
yet they maintain, they still have
some level of chronic pain.
Now, chronic means a lifetime,
that this is a permanent pain
that you're going to experience
if not treated, right?
Or, that there is no treatment.
So, there are various
different treatments.
Chronic pain is defined as
three to six months or more.
So, with plasticity in the nervous system
and there's gene regulation and so forth
that occurs on the nerve level,
on the spinal cord level,
and also, on the brain level.
And so, we develop, emotional challenges
and economic challenges to chronic pain.
With chronic pain obviously,
in addition to debilitating pain
that we perceive, right?
So, yes. It is a longstanding disease.
Much like diabetes,
initially, we had thought
that it's a disturbance
with glucose management.
Glucose was perturbed.
And now, we learn that
there's a metabolic issue
that is much more widespread
with diabetes.
You get retinopathy, nephropathy,
your kidneys go, your eyes go,
you get obese.
And so, there are implications
that are much broader
than the initial insult,
which is the challenges
in glucose management.
Same with chronic pain.
You might have initial nerve injury,
yet that leads to a much broader issue
down the line with chronic pain.
And so, to treat chronic pain,
you really need to think about it
as a multipronged approach,
a comprehensive approach
to treat pharmacologically
various different targets
on different levels.
It sounds so complicated.
Ofer, it sounds like you have to study
for 20 years to just be able to understand
what you're saying here.
But, dumb it down for me.
Because, I'm coming in outside
of the medical arena.
I'm coming in as a young entrepreneur
and I'm trying to think,
how can we leverage  technology
in our day to day lives to improve
people's habits, people's lives.
Now, I build applications,
or I build algorithms that hopefully
will improve people's lives.
You're taking people's lives
that are suffering
and you're actually using medicine
to help them.
Very different from the work that I do.
So, help me understand
a little bit better.
What is the process that you go about
as the chief division of pain medicine,
what are your responsibilities
and what is this world of pain medicine?
How prevalent is it?
How big is it?
Is it really big deal?
Let me start with this.
So, it doesn't take one individual
to treat chronic pain.
It takes a team, right?
So, it takes perhaps a physician
to treat medically
with different medications.
It might take a procedure list
to do injections or use devices
that might be implantable and so forth.
It might take a physical therapist.
It might take a pain psychologist
to work as a team.
Now, today, the biggest problem
over the decades
has been measurement of pain.
How do we know
how much pain one perceives, right?
So, do we do a well test?
Do we look at saliva?
Do we look at
patient reported outcome measures?
And so here comes,
this is where we have big data
come to the rescue, right?
And patients can tell us
on their phones or devices,
Hey, you know,
I'm feeling great today.
I was able to do this much.
I could demonstrate that I was able
to walk this many steps today.
Right.
But what has been
the greatest advancements, let's say,
over the past 20 years in pain medicine?
Has it been really big data
and the ability to now understand
different similarities
and differences amongst patients?
Or, is it more of the medicine itself
that has been developing?
So, I mean, I think that
when I was an age 30 years ago,
almost 20, 30 years ago,
we were looking at using electrodes
to measure pain with animals.
Now, we're able to
put biosensors on human beings
and follow them longitudinally.
And so, that is a huge advance.
And really, it's something that we can,
it's almost a gift
to pharmaceutical companies
and so forth.
Because, now we're able
to have reliable models, if you will,
to look at how well they're,
it's not necessarily a validated tool
for the FDA for approval and so forth.
But it is for physicians giving us a tool
to follow our patients,
not just once a month, but real time.
And by the way,
the CMS has caught on to this.
And CMS is the body
that determines reimbursement
pretty much in this country.
They decide what Medicare pays
and then everybody follows.
All the players follow.
So, what they will been able to say
is that we want people
to be monitored longitudinally, so there's
chronic disease management codes now.
They started just last year,
which is giving a huge boost to apps.
Right?
So, an endocrinologist
will follow a patient
for a certain amount of time every month
and be able to look at them
not just once a month or periodically
or with a log that someone brings you,
but actual data.
Real time, actually with the sensor.
So, these types of things
have now come to a field
that is actually very complex.
And extrapolating this,
this isn't just specifically
about the doctor
following a specific patient.
But, everybody today,
I have right here this ring
that I usually put on.
But my girlfriend doesn't like
when I put it on during the day,
so, I'm taking it off for now.
Sorry, Carly.
And this ring measures
my heart rate constantly,
very accurately measures my sleep.
And today, there are
so many devices around
where an Apple Watch or this ring
where I'm asking these devices
to measure things for me.
Ideally, obviously,
I'd like this to be integrated
with my primary physician so that
they can get an alert automatically.
Like, something's wrong with Michael.
We better reach out.
This is obviously even more important
with people that are sick.
Or I'm thinking about my grandparents,
that irregularities can unfortunately
lead to a tragedy.
And sometimes, it is time that saves.
But Ofer, I'd love to transition
also to MedTech.
Because you have a fascinating
joint responsibility of both
running the division of pain medicine,
but also an investment arm.
Both a part of J-Ventures and outside.
So, talk to me about MedTech in general
and which areas of this
are you excited in?
How do you go about your ideas there?
Right. So, basically, my day job,
if you will, is to care for patients.
And basically, what I has been
is develop a program out east
in Stamford, Connecticut,
that's part of the Columbia system,
Columbia University system.
That you're an assistant professor there.
Right?
Right. Right.
So, we're basically able to develop
a system that will provide outcomes
for patients that we're interested in.
So, we have an inpatient program
for pain management
where we cover patients
in the hospital and optimize
their pain management needs
and thereby optimize hospital outcomes.
And we also have
a population health approach
where we take care of out-patients
with chronic pain.
So, that is what I do.
And I try to drive the bus a little bit
in terms of the philosophy.
But also, we take care of patients
and we love to do it.
By the way, why did you choose
specifically pain medicine
and not any other type of doctor?
Why are you excited about
working with patients with chronic pain?
So, it's a good question.
I mean, it's obviously
a very challenging group of patients.
It's neuroscience.
And I'm a basic scientist.
And I've come from there.
And I was involved in working
with one of the teams
that we're working on one of the receptors
that are integral into chronic pain.
And so, fell into the field.
But I love working with patients
and I enjoy educating.
And I was at Stanford in California
and in a wonderful environment
Looking at pain and studying pain.
And caring for patients
that have rare pain conditions.
And it's just been something
that I really enjoy to do.
And some of these patients
really have difficult stories.
And it's been very rewarding
to at least for some of these patients,
increase their activities daily living,
improve their function.
That's really what it's all about.
How much of this
is investigative Sherlock Holmes?
Like I would need to figure out
why you're feeling this way, versus,
Oh, I've seen your case 100 times.
Here is the prescription.
Go, do these exercises
and let me know how you feel.
Which of the two is it more?
So, I mean, I think it depends
on the type of pain medicine
that you're practicing.
I think that, 90% of a lot of practices
is back pain, neck pain.
And a lot of medicine these days,
it's become very prescriptive, right?
I think that, my model has been
where I work and with my partners is that
we have more of an academic model
and we see patients from regionally
and we see some interesting cases.
And we'd like to spend a lot of time
working with patients cognitively
and making them feel
like they're pumped
when they leave the office.
that they're going to get better.
And we have a plan.
So, it's all about being a good doctor
at the end of the day.
I love that.
And so, yeah, it's all about that.
That's amazing. Okay.
So now, going back to my original question
about MedTech.
Tell me a little bit about
this intersection between you as a doctor,
your responsibilities, caring for patients
and getting that satisfaction.
But also being on the forefront
of these technologies and thinking ahead
of what's coming up next.
Right. So, having trained
in Stanford, in California,
it's a really a wonderful opportunity
to really work with some
really interesting people
and be able to appreciate
some problems in our field.
And work with engineers
and business professionals
and be able to answer
some of those questions and investigate.
So, working in that area, in the region,
it was, I was able to work
with some interesting people,
whether it was Doximity,
or some other folks in the area.
And so, it's been really great
to push the envelope
and really try to bring questions
and needs from the clinic.
And be able to meet some folks,
to be able to accomplish some,
to answer some of those questions.
And to develop some technology
And now, as an early stage investor,
I mean, why J-Ventures?
Why go and be in the MedTech space?
It sounds like you have your hands full,
being the chief division of pain medicine.
Yeah. We certainly don't have much time
on our hands.
But it's just really wonderful
to not only be part of these teams,
but also be able to listen
to what other people have worked on
and really be part of Oded Hermoni's team.
It's just been a wonderful experience
to be part of that kibbutz.
And and learn as well, obviously,
in the process.
And meet some wonderful individuals,
have virtual coffee
with some wonderful individuals.
So, it's just been, I'm very thankful
to be able to be part of that team.
Wonderful.
And listen, I mean, I think that
it's always interesting to innovate
and to think about what's in the future
of our field.
And it's really interesting.
I had a patient several years ago
at the time where
if you asked five people,
I think some of them might have said,
"Telemedicine is never going to work."
I think clearly now,
we think very differently
than most of us would do.
But, someone came to the office
and he was 80 years old
at the time, probably. He said,
"Listen, when I was a kid,
physicians would come to your house."
"And now, I've got to come to the office."
And then it really struck me that,
I was in an office.
there's magazines, there's a waiting room,
and this is just really
an artifact of history, most likely.
Right?
So, now we're able to see the patient.
Used to be horse and buggy,
then we used to come to the house.
For a while we had the office experience.
And I think that in the future,
there will probably be a hybrid.
And we just can get better and better
at not only seeing patients remotely,
but also, as we said,
follow them over time
without necessarily interacting
with them personally.
It might be box,
it might be biosensors and so forth.
I think it was an insane experience.
I mean, it's the right word for it.
It was an insane experience
that I needed last week,
when we chatted,
I wanted to get a covid test
during this crazy pandemic.
And I would like to shift
the conversation to covid as well.
And I got on my phone
and I hopped on with my Stanford doctor
and she asked to see my ID,
hence the phone to know that it's me.
And, within ten minutes
I was done with a referral
and a full diagnosis
of what she thinks
was a follow up over SMS.
And I was blown away, I said,
"Why would I ever want to spend an hour
going to the office,
waiting in the waiting room,
getting sick from somebody else,
potentially, if I could just do it here."
Oh, and by the way, if I can send
my Apple Watch messages to her
and my ring sleep data to her,
then she doesn't she needs to ask me
half the questions
because she has everything already.
So, I think it's incredible.
But Ofer, give me your two cents
on what's happening now.
It's really a unique time,
especially, I'm sure, as a doctor.
So, what's happening?
Where are we headed?
What are some
interesting things over there?
Right. So I think that fortunately,
where I am right now,
in my house where we have
zero cases right now after having
at a peak 150 patients a day with covid.
So, luckily, I think that all the efforts
have been rewarded, at least for now.
I think that you hit the nail on the head.
I mean, I think that
one of the bigger developments with covid
for medicine has been the acceptance.
The wide acceptance of Telehealth
and the amount of investment
that's gone into it.
And really, what's driven this
is the decision,
that was a prudent decision
on the government's part
and CMSs part to basically provide
the same amount of reimbursement
for Telehealth,
as they would for in-person visits.
And once that incentive was done
to see patients personally,
then it was basically,
people did what they thought
would be easier and more efficient.
So, I think it's definitely
going to add efficiency,
not to mention what you said
was about communicable diseases.
You don't want to go to the office
if you're ill.
We do that all the time.
Now, with covid, very clearly,
they'll tell you if you're feeling sick,
you call us and then we determine
what the next step would be.
But for years,we've been going the doctor,
for being sick
with communicable diseases.
So, I think this is a huge change
and hopefully it's here to stay.
And, that's been really interesting.
But Ofer, you're getting satisfaction
from seeing the patients
that you're helping them.
They are thanking you.
You see that now
they're able to walk a little bit better
than they did last week.
And you're getting that satisfaction.
Are you going to get the same satisfaction
getting a WhatsApp video of them doing it?
Or them thanking you over the phone
instead of in person?
Because one of the things
that I'm now worried about is,
is the quality of health care
going to go down because doctors
are going to be a little less personal.
Because now, I'm just another
WhatsApp number.
I'm no longer in hour long session
where the doctor asks me,
Hey, how's your girlfriend,
or how's your dog?
Right. Now, well we have to maintain
a certain level of etiquette, obviously.
But I think that it's interesting.
I've seen patients for years
and I've never seen their kitchen.
Right?
And, all of a sudden,
I see them in their kitchen.
I see them walking their dog
and on the beach.
And I can see how well they're doing,
how well they're walking
and how well they may be
cleaning their house.
And what environment they live in.
Whether they live in a total mess
of an apartment,
or they could actually function.
People that have elderly parents
and they want to see,
they want to be involved in the meeting.
We can have our software that we use
that telemedicine allows us
to pull in the family members.
So, actually, that now allows us
to have a daughter in California
and an elderly patient in Connecticut.
And that's something
that we couldn't do before.
But I mean, not to mention the fact
that right now, listen, I mean, medicine,
this in the laboratories,
has been centralized.
So, there's a centralized model.
So, if you are going to get a test
for BRCA1, for example,
which is a gene we look for
in breast cancer,
all those tests go to one company.
Because they do high throughput
and they do it most efficiently
and cheapest, right?
And they have the patent for it.
So, in medicine, we still have,
pain physicians in every town
or we hope there is.
A neurosurgeon in nearly every town.
Right?
And we're limited to the market
that like a community bank.
But now we have access
to expertise anywhere.
So, you could be living in somewhere.
They may not be a metropolitan area
and you want to see a specialist
on some neuroendocrine tumor,
and that person might be in New York City
or MD Anderson in Texas,
and now you're able to access
that individual.
So, that is a huge accomplishment for us
on a national scale.
To be able to offer,
level the playing field for patients.
Incredible. I think, yeah.
I mean, I'm looking back I grew up
with severe severe eye problems.
Where growing up, I was basically
with a wet towel on my eyes and sunglasses
and nobody had any idea what's happening.
And we crossed seas
in order for me to see experts
so that they can take a look at my eye
and try to figure out what's happening,
and I obviously couldn't get access
to have the doctors that I wanted to,
mainly because of geographical barriers.
And the end, it was one doctor in Tel Aviv
coming from Russia who said
that by the age of 12, it will pass.
And it passed at the age of 12.
On my birthday, of course.
Whatever experts we went to
was it was good.
But I completely agree.
And I think it's inspiring.
And I learned so much
with this conversation.
So, I want to thank you
again for your time.
Really amazing.
But Ofer, before we leave,
I have to ask you
the most important question,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Well, that's a tough one.
I hated to be put on the spot.
But I would like to be humble.
I'll use that as one of them.
inquisitive.
And I hope to be innovative and helpful.
Humble, inquisitive and innovative.
I love it. Ofer, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
Thank you for the service you're doing.
Thank you for helping people.
Now at Stanford, but now it's going to be
around the world because everybody
is going to have access to Ofer
through their mobile phone.
So, thank you very much.
Thanks for doing this.
I really appreciate it.
Take care.